in the lobby of Ramsey solutions Joe and
Bethany are with us hey guys how are ya
great Dave how are you I am better than
I deserve
welcome welcome where are you from San
Diego California Oh fun welcome to
Nashville that's a bit of a haul to do a
debt-free scream yes but we are super
excited to be here well we're excited to
have you how much have you paid off we
paid off a hundred and forty four
thousand dollars whoa and how long did
that take thirty months okay cool and
your range of income during that time
it's about a hundred two hundred fifty
very good all right and what do you guys
do for a living I am a director for
children youth and families in San Diego
mm-hmm and I am a musician oh very cool
that's why the range yes and zone if the
gigs are there and what kind of musician
I play a bunch of instruments saxophone
vocals guitar piano doing a lot of a lot
of like hotels country clubs weddings
corporate stuff cool good steady good
steady flow again yeah good good for you
all right what kind of uh that was the
hundred and forty four thousand dollars
no right well the big dog was the
student loans of course mostly for me
that was about a hundred and five
thousand Wow yeah what's your degree in
I have a few I have a couple of masters
all kind of working with children and
families in educational psychology and
I'm also a licensed Marriage and Family
Therapist okay Wow good for you fine all
right so what happened 30 months ago two
and a half years ago something happened
and you said okay we're gonna get
serious about this getting out of death
thing yeah so we took Financial Peace
University through our church and I
think kind of in the middle of it it
just really the light bulb came on and
especially with the student loan debt it
we were drowning in that and not making
any headway and so saying what are we
doing for our future what we got to do
something different and everything just
fell into place what you teach it just
makes sense and so we're like let's do
this let's vote
let's change our future you know about
five years ago
her sister gave us a Financial Peace
University money makeover Total Money
Makeover for our wedding mm-hmm and like
oh that's good I kind of read through it
you know but something clicked when we
went to the class I think you know the
guy teaching it was probably a big part
of it
yeah the gays yelling at you the whole
times like sergeant Carter boot camp
right I mean not only just the just the
money aspect but the whole umbrella of
you know the the insurance and and all
that stuff that it covers it just this
makes sense yeah we should probably take
this seriously Andy listen we got on
fire yeah and it made you believe you
could do it absolutely yeah that's cool
yeah well very proud of you too that's a
lot of money to pay off in 3 in 30
months I mean that's kicking butt yeah
did you sell stuff no well actually he
got creative we live in a condo and so
he didn't have a yard but he did a
sidewalk sale so he went out on a
Saturday morning and I don't know if is
100% legal or but used a sidewalk and
sold some stuff nothing in California is
a hundred percent legal Wow way to go
you guys this is very very cool thank
you so how does it feel now I mean
anything absolutely amazing I think
we're it's still a little bit surreal
our goal was to complete do our final
payment by the birth of our child he's
with us today she's three months and so
our final payment was July 8 and she was
due the 12th but she actually came early
on July 4th Oh
and so she's a firecracker baby here we
go
and so we that was really our goal is to
completely get out of debt to really set
her up technically our goal when we
first started I think it was like five
six years yeah that off and then as you
say you know it just kind of gets
shorter and shorter what if we could pay
this off by Christmas what if we could
pay this off by Thanksgiving what if we
could do it yeah before Geneva is born
what if we work a little bit here and
sell that thing and twist that and and
don't go out to eat here and you start
seeing yeah and you get fired up
absolutely anything
also with us both being on athletics all
of our lives we are super competitive
and so it was like what can we do how
can we do this even faster and get done
and so that competitive spirit I think
helped a lot too yeah so you said your
sister gave you the book at the wedding
yes what's she saying about all this
she's she my whole family my parents are
actually here flew out from Oregon to be
here for our debt free scream - yeah
yeah our families are just so supportive
she's amazing and actually that just
inspired them to really become more
focused too in their journey and also it
also since it was I mean 30 months when
you're in it yeah you know it's like
brutal so that that helped that helped
us we had a lot of support from friends
and family it's brutal what was the
hardest part for y'all I think that we
we had a lot of time apart from each
other we're really big into our love
languages and both of us like time
together and so he was just doing a ton
of gigs I was working three different
jobs I'm also an adjunct professor and I
do trainings for various nonprofits in
San Diego and so we were just non-stop
working yeah especially so I was in an
original band for a while doing tours
and stuff and then I came back to San
Diego and did cover song stuff mm-hm and
it started off slower for me and then
all of a sudden like the last 30 you
know three years more opportunity came
in and I'd look at her and I said well I
got an opportunity to do this and make
this money and just the the ability to
have you know I feel like God just hi
Geneva ready to do the screen yeah I
feel like the more focused and diligent
we were with our finances the more
opportunity God gave us you know when
you're know and I would look at Bethenny
and I'd be like this means I'm not gonna
be here for this or that she said just
do it game on we support each other in
that and just worked worked as much as
because you work like no one else later
you can work like no no yeah and you can
live and give like no one else you drive
like no one else later you can drive
like no one else you paid the price
Bible says no discipline seems Pleasant
at the time that it yields a harvest of
righteousness you guys are incredible
very very proud of you ain't very cool
so
we've got a copy of Chris Hogan's retire
inspired book number one bestseller for
you signed by him that will take you to
the next level that's the next chapter
in your story because now you go from
you know being burdened down by student
loans now you build wealth and now you
become outrageously generous and you'll
be in a position to do that and change
your whole family tree and so forth okay
do we want to put Geneva in the shatar
we're gonna leave her with Grandma Iran
over here a shirt made oh yeah and how
old is she she is three months oh and
what's that what's the shirt say it says
debt-free I love it she's ready doors
creak making a hundred to one hundred
and fifty joke Bethenny and Geneva from
San Diego count it down let's hear a
debt free scream
that is so awesome that is so freaking
awesome well done you guys I'm very
proud of you man that's incredible
that's how it's done
hey guys thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video click the subscribe
button to get the latest content and
check out these other great clips from
the show you can do this you know that
really is a message whether you've got
two hundred seventy thousand dollars in
student loan debt or 27 thousand well
you've got a fifty thousand dollar
income or $500,000 in common